contrary to what people think about
writing and writing stories specifically
and within that even writing drama um
it's not
you know a burst of sudden inspiration
there's something very
mathematical uh methodological
in how to construct an engineer well
told story
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford this episode is all about
telling stories and
really important ones meet bos gaon the
ceo and founder of wisdo
an award-winning platform going beyond
the social graph by connecting people to
others who've been there
are helpful and are available to chat
within 10 seconds and less
wisdo reduces feelings of isolation by
70 percent within the first two weeks of
using the app
boaz founded wiz though after losing his
father to cancer and witnessing up close
how unnecessarily impossible it is in
times of need
to find someone who ticks all three
boxes someone who's helpful
relevant and instantly available
previous to wisdom
boss was a journalist and social
activist boa is gone thank you for
joining me how are you today
hey michael how are you i'm fantastic
i'm can't wait to talk about you know
what you're doing to tackle
the loneliness epidemic that is not only
triggered by covet but it's been with us
for so long and is only growing and
obviously you know the world
is changing and i can't wait to pick
your brain on how the changing world
is either adapting or misadapting to our
loneliness epidemic
and but also talk about your you as a
playwright
and you did your bachelor's of arts in
theater and play writing from television
university
then on to doing your masters and and
global communications
in the london in london and i just need
to know how everything pieces together
so boss before we really get
into what you do with wisdom talk to me
about yourself how do you get started
how do you go from playwriting to tech
um well it's not that uh big a jump
uh i think that would that's what a
writer would tell you or someone who is
uh
you know a kind of uh spends his life
engineering stories uh because contrary
to what people
think about writing and writing stories
specifically
and within that even writing drama um
it's not
you know a burst of sudden inspiration
there's something very
mathematical uh methodological
in how to construct an engineer well
told story
um and um i think that what we do when
we start
a company or we have some sort of vision
is you know we we
have something in mind that we want to
try and build that would attract people
and we'll build an audience over time
and keep people engaged
um so um i think that one of the
skills that um you know people need to
acquire as they start this journey
towards building a company
um is something that not is often
you know talked about or looked at which
is the ability to
construct and tell a well uh constructed
story
right you're gonna have to tell the
story when you
uh raise money when you hire people
uh when you launch a feature uh
when you start making money uh when you
start having conversations with your
audience
um and and the last thing that i would
say about about this is
another i think misunderstood aspect of
storytelling
is that it's not only uh a means of
communicating
it's also a really uh effective tool
in identifying the core of
anything at all so for example when when
you're gonna sit in a room
and a thousand people are gonna have
different ideas about what the company
should be
or what the product should be then
you're gonna have to go back and say
okay what is our story you know who are
we
who are we not you know what's the
villain
uh that we're trying to beat um in our
case it's you know loneliness
uh and isolation um and how do we do
that you know what are the actions
we're gonna take um so all that comes
together uh and maybe you know this is
just
through my own filter with someone who
was a storyteller and is but i think
it's a very um
uh their overlap there is real
so talk to me a little bit about the
process of of writing a play
i i before we get to visual because
because i it's very rare that i get to
talk to somebody who's actually writing
plays and puts on
and puts them on later and sees them
come to life so walk me through that
you know at this at the start of journey
of writing a play
until you see it actually on the stage
what is the process like what do you
have to do
as sort of like the ceo and the and you
know the the mastermind behind
this whole thing mastermind uh you know
that
is something that um i don't know if i
can live up to but um
you know writing a story or writing a
play uh again much like
doing anything creative and i think you
know starting the company is
certainly one of them um it starts with
a very
personal uh pain point so
uh you you know you go through life
suddenly you're
faced with something that is very
troubling or makes you very mad
um or you know it's very painful or very
emotional and you try to
really translate that into a bigger
creation
that can open up the conversation with
more people instead of just containing
it within yourself that that is really
the whole
idea of a creative process um as for
writing a play
um once you've identified that you want
to commit to that
and i think that's the real first
question i mean do you is this an idea
that you want to spend a year or two
years or three years of your life on uh
or is this the swim
um and once you have identified that
this is a world that you want to dive
into
the first question is going to be who's
the hero
uh you know who's our protagonist uh
who's that
you know once upon a time there was a
who
uh and then uh you start with coming up
with a
um you know a situation a dramatic
situation
where that specific protagonist wants
something
uh and and can't get that
and you know you're trying to think
about what's the most interesting
uh kind of first scene uh that you can
start with
that would the protagonist very uh
close to understanding that this is not
something that is going to happen he's
going to go and
and he's going to have to go and fight
for this thing to happen
uh feedback on this whole process so
obviously i'm i'm seeing
i'm i'm picturing you you know i'm
pitching you like in this picturesque
resort
like looking at the ocean and writing
you know a bunch of pages of of course
that's not necessarily the case but
but then you know you like like in a
startup you you get a product and
now you have to like can you do an mvp
with the play is that even a thing
can you do something like that and get
feedback yeah well first of all it's
more
more of a it's midnight and you're
you're in you're in your underwear
[Music]
and uh you're trying to get through the
night um
because you can't get you're obsessed
with this idea that you just had
um um and as for mvp
um you know not really uh
it needs to get to a point where at
least you can have
um and that that's by the way one of the
good things that happened with
one of the very few things that that
that is good in the karana age
i think this whole idea of you know
virtual
conversations online has become
something that is now
part of all of our lives so for example
um
one thing that has been happening in the
um you know drama and
acting scene here in israel is that a
lot of factors are open to
reading uh early work um right or zoom
or
you know google meet or whatever uh and
you can get a sense of
uh whether this is working or not but
there's gonna be a phase like when
you're starting
working just to work on a feature um or
a
you know company or or um you know
anything that would
eventually have have to launch where
it's basically you
uh a small group of people that you
trust
um an instinct whether this is going uh
in the right direction
and and experience um you know
the more you do it the better you're
gonna get at identifying whether this is
going
somewhere or not and then at some point
yeah you're going to have to give this
to a bunch of actors to read
much like launching a you know feature
for a thousand people
um in a closed beta uh
and see what happens um and then you
know um
sometimes you go well that was an
interesting experience and you know on
to the next idea
sometimes you go that was unbelievable
sometimes you go well
that part was really strong this part
needs to
you know needs to be cut completely from
the from
from the play and um and then it's just
iterating towards a
uh you know an approved version well i
think that that's just one of run
i'm guessing that at the end the sort of
the product launch is
getting to getting to the stage getting
that feedback that's sort of like the
product contour you're seeing like the
that
you know people sales go up and the turn
rate and then whether you get the new
release of some more products and i
think i think that's just so fascinating
and i i'm a big musical guy my brother
is on broadway
so i've been fascinated by this whole by
this whole thing and i think it's
especially fascinating that
on one hand you're running you're
running wisdom with a remarkable mission
and a remarkable story and now i can see
why the story is so clear
and and so you know um very engaging
with
whoever listens to it so now tell me a
little bit about
before you even tell me about wisdom
tell me about the loneliness epidemic
that that has swept through the world
you know
since you know especially in the mid
20th century
and and going on today yeah
well it's just like you said there's an
epidemic uh that predates the the
uh the covet pandemic which is
um uh people feeling more lonely and
isolated than ever before
and what we've noticed and you know
obviously it all starts with a personal
experience but eventually when we did
like
did look at the data uh trying to
understand you know what's going on we
did see
a contradictory um two contradictory
trends
one is more people connected to more
people than ever before in the history
of humankind
uh via you know social networks and the
online
um you know products are available via
online but at the same time more people
define themselves as lonely
and isolated than ever before and these
two things don't seem to
kind of match up you know how is it
possible that more people feel
more more disconnected in this age where
right we're all in the age of
connectivity
exactly or you know ultra connectivity
and you know
right connectivity and when you dive
deeper into that you find
that the reason is that the people that
were introduced to
um online are not necessarily the people
who can make this feel more connected
and less isolated and better about
who we are where we are and where we can
get to
and when you double click on that and we
did um
you find that the reason for that is
because when you're introduced to other
people online
primarily via social networks uh the
organizing criteria
is one people who are popular
so people are ranked by how many helpful
uh likes they have
friends they have followers they have um
and that creates a certain
uh competition uh because of those guys
because you know all of you are part of
this high school schoolyard
um right fighting over who's going to be
more popular
uh even though you might be in your 70s
and 60s or 50s and you should have been
way way over that phase of your life
um and the second part is you're gonna
be introduced to people who you're
already connected to somehow
so these are friends of friends of
friends and friends right and again
that's gonna create a tension between
you and those guys
where it's going to be you know do i
want to
say that you know what are they going to
say you know i might meet them later on
what's that going to do to who i
am and all that while when you're faced
with a
moment in life that requires uh you know
meeting people who can help you feel
more connected and more supported
um we found out that a different set of
criteria that would put in place
can change that whole behavior and those
three criteria is one
people who've been in your shoes even if
you don't know them
even if it's people that you would never
ever meet on facebook or instagram or
any of these guys
because they're not in your social graph
there's no overlap
um but they've been in your shoes and
know exactly what you're talking about
um the second is people who ranked by
helpfulness
rather than popularity so how do you do
that
that's a longer product discussion but
basically you try to work into
the product experience data points that
you can
leverage so you can promote people who
are more more helpful i'll give you one
very simple example
we don't have a like button we have a
helpful
uh reaction so the more helpful
reactions you earn from other people on
the platform
the higher your helpfulness uh right
core
and then we also look at you know speed
of response
uh and we look at you know just overall
activity
uh and other things and obviously
similarity between you and that person
um right and then the third criteria is
going to be is going to be availability
because that's another thing that we
found a sense of disconnection often
is exacerbates when you reach out to
someone and that person doesn't answer
so we're going to find out whether we
can within seconds connect you with
someone who's helpful
who's been in your shoes and is
available to chat within seconds
um i think that's wonderful that's very
very cool
and boss tell me a little bit so wisdo
is a mobile application i know that it
won
numerous awards both from apple and
google it was featured on the new york
times and all the major publications and
i think that
the mission of what you're doing is is
particularly important and and i'm
watching
you know both my generation and the
generations after me
progressing into a world that with with
the hyper connectivity
at the same time it's it's i wouldn't
say shallow but it's just much more
difficult to form these meaningful
connections
given that the pla that it's one big
playing field
where you know it's conflicting but
you're both friends but you're also
frenemies right
online and and it's very difficult so
one of the things that i notice on the
platform is that you're you're you tag
people
as helpful mentor mentee but
in my mind everybody is sort of the same
right i i am a mentor to some people i'm
helpful to some but i need help on a lot
of things myself and i need
to be a mentee by from other people so
how does this how does the whole
ecosystem work in your mind
yeah so um the the journey is often
people come to wisdo because they're
looking for
uh you know mentorship and support and
inspiration
and all these things but then as they
find that
we show them other people that they can
help
and support and inspire their own
uh you know life and about a quarter of
people who come to wisdo to find support
um
and inspiration step up and become
helpers and then you know
start their journey towards becoming a
guide and a coach and all those things
um one thing that we did crack in the
onboard
uh which was one of our turning points
for us was
as he joined wisto um we asked you sort
of what's in your mind what are you
going through
news anxiety or heartbreak or falling in
love or
college or any one of these things uh
but then instead of dropping you into
a group with thousands and hundreds of
thousands of people
we show you a list of events or moments
along that journey
that other people have experienced and
then people go
been there been there been there been
there
and then the other click is there now
there now they're now
there now and what we found out into
your question is
when when you click a bin there we show
you how many people you can help
wow because you've learned something
amazing
and when you click there now we show you
how many people can help you
so i love that uh thank you so
immediately
you get a sense that yes i'm here to
find support
but also i do have stuff to share with
other folks
and i'm guessing it's somewhere along
the same line of you know if
if i'm able to if i teach somebody
something i learn it myself much better
i'm sort of forced to learn and i'm
guessing that
somebody if i if i feel that i need help
and in some domain
even just by helping somebody else on
another domain
just that boost of confidence and that
that interactivity
already gives me the boost that will
help me also go through my own journey
and i'm guessing that it's like this
this beautiful cycle that that is just
never ending because every year
your sort of two-sided marketplace is
sort of they're both one side that they
just keep rotating positions right
exactly and we also you know we also
gonna we're gonna recommend
things that we think you uh maybe know
more
less about after you've done something
so for example you might have come into
as though
um through call the college experience
we're going to say hey
um you know you might want to take a
look at anxiety so
um because we know the 50 of people who
join
the college related communities that end
up joining the
anxiety communities so the fact that we
know in the back end kind of what leads
into what
kind of mapping out life uh to some
extent
helps to identify where we think you
uh the areas where we think you can find
support from from
some people and then areas where maybe
you can offer some support to other
people
right how what is the tension between or
the fine line between
you know this non-clinical
uh no non-clinical environment
versus you know therapy a lot of these
things a lot of these
keywords that you've mentioned are they
sound to me like something that you
would go to a therapist
to see uh and i'm guessing that here in
this in this marketplace it's not
therapists it's people just like you
that have just
have gone through your experience and
now they're able to help you through
because they've experienced it
themselves yeah no so it's not therapy
um it's you know the the the um uh
metaphor that we always use is like you
know imagine you you're sitting on the
train
uh and someone comes in you don't know
anything about them
but somehow you know they get a phone or
something somehow you find out that both
of you
have either become a dad recently or
started a company
or lost a dad or uh you know had
surgery or fell in love or any one of
these things
you're gonna be talking for the next two
hours even though you don't know that
person at all
just because there's uh you know a lot
there's a lot of wisdom to share
and i don't think that any one of us in
that situation would expect that person
to offer clinical
advice uh unless that person happens to
be a psychologist
so we answer to that part of life uh we
just do it digitally and
and apparently effectively uh what we've
begun to do lately
uh is use the fact that we know how to
map out
um you know these journeys to identify
moments where people might be
looking for professional advice
and then we showcase them on the
platform as people who can offer
either you know some coaching sessions
uh if they're a certified life coach or
um a therapy session if they're a
licensed therapist
um but um you know that is very clearly
identified as
you know that that type of session
versus uh
you know peer support 100 i think that i
i think that what you're doing is just
it's so interesting i i
am fascinated by where this world is
going and i'm mainly extended by the
fact that there are people like you that
are that are dealing with it to
something great i think that
unfortunately still you know nine out of
10 entrepreneurs aren't
dealing with these things perhaps
they're just not as sexy as
you know the hyper hyper growth markets
that are that are that are going but i
think that what you're doing is
is tremendously more important and i
think that we all need to take it to
take a check on
on what technol what technologies do we
need to be building so that we can have
a safe
a safe relationship with our with our
devices
and with our world so so thank you boss
for doing that and for for the
inspiration that i'm getting from this
before we're leaving i wanna thank you
for being also generous with your time
and ask you the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
oh um you mean in addition to israeli
no of course no let's say
i think um hard-working
um honest
um and um
um it's it's too many words but i miss
my dad i think that
that that is kind of goes back to the
genesis of wisdom but we can talk about
that in a different
time i love that boss thank you very
very much
stay safe stay healthy and i can't wait
to first of all join wisdom myself
and both as a helper and as a lp
and and i look forward to to keeping in
touch over there thank you very much
all the best